(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre ação de
consignação em pagamento que alguns leilões extrajudiciais apresentam
ou outros tipos de ações prévias que um
leilão extrajudicial possa ter.
O leiloeiro é sempre obrigado a informar eventuais
processos pendentes que existam sobre os imóveis que
ele está leiloando.
Então, em alguns casos de leilão extrajudicial, ao
analisar a página do leiloeiro, o interessado vai
encontrar uma informação de que consta uma ação
de consignação em pagamento ou que consta algum
outro tipo de ação sobre aquele imóvel.
O que significa uma ação de consignação em
pagamento?
Basicamente, ação de consignação em pagamento é ação
movida pelo devedor contra o credor por três
motivos.
O primeiro, quando o credor se recusa a
receber o valor.
O segundo, quando existe dúvida sobre quem é
o credor.
E o terceiro, quando há litígio sobre o
E como é que isso aplica ao leilão
extrajudicial?
A gente falou aqui nesse módulo 2 que
é um requisito para que o credor fiduciário
consolide a propriedade, que ele constitua o devedor
fiduciante em mora.
E o que significa constituir em mora?
Significa notificar oficialmente que aquele devedor está devendo
ao credor.
Então, esse é um dos requisitos para a
consolidação da propriedade, que o credor constitui o
devedor em mora.
A partir do momento que ele constituir em
mora, vai abrir um prazo de 15 dias
para que o devedor ele purga mora, ou
seja, ele pague aquilo que ele está devendo.
Se ele não pagar, aí sim o credor
pode consolidar a propriedade em seu nome e
uma vez consolidando a propriedade em seu nome,
ele vai ser obrigado a realizar leilão extrajudicial
para quitar a dívida daquele devedor.
Então, a ação de consignação em pagamento entra
no leilão extrajudicial exatamente quando o ele toma
ciência de que o imóvel dele está indo
a leilão.
A gente falou que um dos requisitos para
o leilão extrajudicial é que o devedor ele
seja notificado das datas do primeiro e do
segundo leilão.
Por que ele deve ser notificado?
Vamos recapitular aqui.
Ele deve ser notificado porque até a data
do segundo leilão, ele tem preferência para arrematar
aquele imóvel.
Ele tem preferência para arrematar aquele imóvel em
quais condições?
Ele vai ter que quitar toda a dívida
daquele imóvel, ou seja, toda a dívida de
seu contrato de alienação fiduciária e não só
o que ele estava devendo antes da consolidação
da propriedade.
Vamos voltar um pouquinho mais.
A gente falou que para consolidar a propriedade,
o credor deve constituir o devedor em mora
e a gente falou que não existe um
número de parcelas fixos na lei para que
isso aconteça, que cada contrato de alienação fiduciária
vai colocar à disposição, se vai ser necessário
que o devedor atrase, uma, duas, três, cinco
parcelas para que o credor possa começar esse
procedimento.
Então, quando o credor constitui o devedor em
mora, o devedor, para que aquele contrato de
alienação fiduciária continue existindo normalmente, ele deve quitar
só aquilo que ele está em atraso efetivamente.
Então, se o contrato de alienação fiduciária colocou
que seria necessário três parcelas em atraso para
que o credor pudesse começar esse procedimento para
consolidar a propriedade em seu nome, uma vez
constituído em mora o devedor, o devedor só
teria que colocar aquelas parcelas que ele estava
devendo em dia.
Se ele colocasse em dia, o contrato de
alienação fiduciária seguiria normalmente.
Só que no segundo leilão, o direito de
preferência dele não é só para ele colocar
aquilo que ele estava devendo inicialmente até a
consolidação da propriedade.
A gente já falou que o devedor, para
exercer o direito de preferência dele, ele vai
ter que quitar a integralidade daquele contrato.
Então, ele vai ter que pagar todo o
valor daquele contrato e mais os encargos daquele
contrato e mais o valor que o credor
pagou de TBI para consolidar a propriedade em
seu nome.
A gente falou, inclusive, que é muito difícil
que um devedor exerça esse direito de preferência.
Se o devedor não tinha somente o número
de parcelas estipulado em contrato para que o
credor começasse esse processo de consolidação da propriedade
em seu nome, como é que, em um
curto prazo, ele vai conseguir um montante muito
maior do que aquele valor?
É muito difícil que um devedor exerça o
direito de propriedade então.
Então, vamos voltar à ação de consignação em
pagamento.
A consignação em pagamento em leilão extrajudicial existe
quando o devedor toma ciência de que seu
imóvel efetivamente vai a leilão.
Ele vai ser notificado da data do leilão
e, a partir da notificação da data do
leilão, pode ser que ele entre nessa ação
de consignação em pagamento.
A ação de consignação em pagamento, no caso
do leilão extrajudicial, ela vai ter como objetivo
impedir que aquele leilão aconteça.
E como é que o devedor vai mover
essa ação de consignação em pagamento?
Ele vai fazer um pedido para que aquele
leilão não aconteça e, geralmente, o devedor só
vai pagar aquilo que ele estava devendo até
o momento anterior à consolidação da propriedade.
Ou seja, se o contrato colocou lá que
eram necessários três parcelas em atraso para que
o credor começasse esse processo de consolidação da
propriedade, o devedor, quando ele entra com essa
ação de consignação em pagamento, geralmente ele vai
depositar somente aquelas três parcelas, os juros que
incidiu sobre aquelas três parcelas e não vai
depositar o montante do contrato.
E o que acontece com essa ação de
consignação em pagamento?
Na maioria dos casos, essa ação é jogada
em procedente.
Por quê?
Porque o entendimento é que, uma vez consolidada
a propriedade no nome do credor, não basta
que o devedor pague somente o que ele
estava devendo antes da consolidação da propriedade.
Ele deve pagar todo o montante da dívida
e os encargos que incidam sobre aquela dívida.
Então, vamos para o exemplo prático.
Em um caso específico, o contrato de alienação
fiduciária estipulou que seria necessário atraso de três
parcelas de financiamento para que o credor pudesse
começar o processo de consolidação da propriedade.
Então, o devedor atrasou três parcelas, o credor
constituiu esse devedor embora, falou oficialmente que esse
devedor estava devendo e que esse devedor deveria
pagar essas três parcelas em 15 dias.
O devedor não pagou, o credor consolidou a
propriedade em seu nome e levou o imóvel
a leilão.
Quando o devedor toma ciência desse leilão, ele
vai tentar entrar com uma ação de consigninação
em pagamento tentando pagar somente essas três parcelas
que estavam em atraso ou as parcelas que
venceram até a data do efetivo leilão.
Vamos supor que, inicialmente, ele devia três, até
o leilão ser realizado, ele passou a dever
seis parcelas.
Então, esse devedor vai entregar essa ação de
consigninação em pagamento e vai depositar o valor
dessas seis parcelas com juros que incidiram sobre
essas seis parcelas.
Qual é o entendimento?
O entendimento é que o devedor não pode
fazer isso.
Caso ele queira impedir um leilão, ele poderia
usar o seu direito de preferência, mas para
ele usar o seu direito de preferência, ele
tem que quitar a integralidade daquele processo.
Então, vamos supor que, nesse mesmo caso, ainda
faltassem 100 parcelas para o devedor quitar determinado
financiamento.
Então, para ele exercer o direito de preferência
dele, não basta que ele depositasse somente as
seis que venceram até a data do leilão,
ele teria que depositar as 100 parcelas.
Então, para demover uma ação de consigninação em
pagamento e essa ação de consigninação em pagamento
ser julgada procedente pela justiça, ou seja, a
justiça falar que realmente o devedor tinha direito
a impedir aquele leilão, não bastaria que o
devedor depositasse o valor dessas seis parcelas na
justiça.
Ele teria que depositar as 100 parcelas e
nem seria necessário recorrer à justiça, porque o
direito de preferência dele é um direito expresso
na lei.
Iria bastar que ele chegasse ao credor e
quitasse a integralidade daquele processo.
Ele não precisaria da justiça para isso, mas
existem alguns casos que o devedor tenta ver
se esse argumento dele vai colar, dele pagar
só o que ele devia, porque pode ser
que ele não tenha o valor para pagar
a integralidade daquele contrato, ou seja, para quitar
aquele contrato e exercer o seu direito de
preferência.
Então, ele recorre à justiça para ver se
dá certo isso dele só depositar as seis
e impedir que aquele leilão judicial ocorra.
O que acontece na maioria dos casos dessas
ações de consigninação em pagamento?
Essas ações de consigninação em pagamento geralmente são
julgadas em procedente, exatamente porque, para que o
devedor tivesse direito de impedir aquele leilão, ele
deveria pagar a integralidade daquele leilão, ou seja,
exercer o direito de preferência dele.
E ele não faz isso quando entra com
uma ação de consigninação em pagamento.
Ele deposita em juízo somente aquilo que ele
estava devendo.
Então, para resumir toda essa história, o devedor,
quando ele tem ciência de que efetivamente vai
acontecer um leilão numa data X sobre o
imóvel dele, ele vai tentar desesperadamente correr atrás
do credor para impedir que aquele leilão aconteça.
Ele vai chegar no credor e vai falar,
olha, da data que você me constituiu imora
até a data do leilão, eu estou te
devendo aqui, por exemplo, seis parcelas.
Eu pago essas seis parcelas aqui e a
gente segue com o nosso contrato de alienação
financiária, segue tudo normalmente.
O credor vai falar, não, eu não quero
isso, porque eu consolidei a propriedade em meu
nome e, a partir do momento que eu
consolido a propriedade em meu nome, o imóvel
só não vai a leilão se você exercer
o seu direito de preferência.
E como o devedor pode exercer o direito
de preferência dele?
Quitando integralmente aquele contrato e não pagando só
o que ele estava em atraso até a
data da consolidação do pagamento.
O devedor vai falar, mas eu não tenho
dinheiro para quitar a integralidade desse contrato.
O credor vai falar, então, sinto muito, o
leilão vai acontecer porque é isso que a
lei fala que eu posso fazer.
Uma vez consolidada a propriedade em meu nome,
eu obrigatoriamente tenho que realizar um leilão.
O devedor, então, a partir do momento que
ele não consegue um acordo com o credor
para impedir que aquele leilão aconteça, ele vai
tentar uma via judicial para impedir que aquele
leilão aconteça.
Ele pode entrar com a chamada ação de
consignação em pagamento.
Nessa ação de consignação em pagamento, ele vai
falar que o credor se recusou a receber
o valor que ele tinha para pagar e
vai tentar depositar em juízo somente o valor
que ele estava devendo até a data do
efetivo leilão.
Essa ação de consignação em pagamento, na maioria
dos casos, é julgada em procedente porque o
entendimento é o mesmo.
O devedor, ele tem o direito de exercer
o direito de preferência dele, só que para
exercer o direito de preferência dele, ele tem
que quitar integralmente aquele contrato.
Se ele não quita, se ele quer só
pagar as parcelas em atraso, esse argumento não
tem qualquer validade perante ao credor, porque uma
vez que o credor, ele consolida a propriedade
em seu nome, ele obrigatoriamente tem que fazer
o leilão extrajudicial.
E aí, o que pode acontecer quando o
devedor entra com uma ação de consignação em
pagamento?
Pode ser que esse devedor, ele tenta entrar
com uma ação de consignação em pagamento e
peça uma medida liminar.
Essa medida liminar seria exatamente para suspender a
realização de um leilão enquanto um juiz não
decide se ele poderia ou não pagar só
aquilo que ele está devendo.
Se o juiz conceder a liminar, ok, o
banco não vai realizar aquele leilão, aquele leilão
vai ficar suspenso até uma determinação da justiça
falando que não, que realmente o credor deve
realizar aquele leilão, que aquela ação de consignação
em pagamento não tinha o menor fundamento, que
se o ele deveria pagar a integralidade daquele
contrato para impedir que o seu imóvel fosse
a leilão.
Ou pode ser que o juiz, ao analisar
essa liminar, já fale de pronto que esse
processo não tem qualquer fundamento, ele não vai
julgar o processo naquele exato momento, mas ele
não vai definir a liminar, porque exatamente um
requisito para que seja definida uma liminar no
processo judicial é que tem um mínimo de
embasamento, é que tem um mínimo de comprovação
de que aquele processo, ao final, vai ser
julgado procedente.
Então, existindo esse mínimo de comprovação que aquele
processo, ao final, vai ser julgado procedente, o
juiz, ele pode antecipar os efeitos daquele processo,
ele pode conceder a liminar.
E abrindo um parêntese aqui, é exatamente isso
que acontece na ação de emissão na posse.
O juiz, ele pode conceder a liminar para
a emissão na posse exatamente porque tem esse,
o que a gente chama de fumaça do
bom direito, existe toda uma probabilidade que, um
para o arrematante, que ao final daquele processo,
realmente o processo vai ser procedente.
Então, o juiz, ele pode antecipar a liminar.
Isso não acontece em uma ação de consignação
em pagamento, porque provavelmente aquela ação, ao final,
vai ser julgada em procedente.
A justiça vai falar que aquele devedor fiduciante
não tinha o direito de pagar só o
que, só aquilo que ele entendia até a
data do leilão, que ele tinha que quitar
a integralidade.
Então, pode ser que um juiz não determine
essa liminar.
Se o juiz não determinar essa liminar, o
leilão pode ocorrer normalmente.
O credor vai continuar com o procedimento do
leilão que ele já estava fazendo e aquele
leilão vai acontecer normalmente e pode ser que
você, como interessado, arremate aquele imóvel.
E agora existe a pergunta.
Se eu arrematar esse imóvel que já tinha
uma ação prévia e, ao final, aquela ação
for julgada procedente e ficar estipulado que o
credor não poderia ter realizado aquele leilão, o
que acontece comigo que arrematei aquele imóvel?
Eu vou perder o meu dinheiro?
Aqui entra a chamada evicção dos direitos que
os editais de leilão extrajudiciais colocam à disposição.
O que é evicção de direito?
Evicção nada mais é do que a perda
de um bem em razão de uma decisão
judicial que julgou algo que aconteceu antes da
aquisição daquele bem.
Então, como é que se aplicaria a evicção
num leilão extrajudicial?
A justiça julgaria algo que aconteceu antes da
realização daquele leilão, anulando aquele leilão e anulando,
por consequência, a arrematação que você fez.
Então, pode ser que uma decisão judicial analise
um erro que aconteceu no procedimento que levou
aquele imóvel ao leilão ou até mesmo um
erro no contrato de alienação fiduciária que deveria
impedir que aquele leilão acontecesse, mas o leilão
já aconteceu.
Então, pode ser que a justiça determine que
aquele leilão seja anulado e que a pessoa
que arrematou aquele bem vai perder aquele bem.
E aí, o arrematante vai perder o dinheiro
que ele investiu?
Não, porque a evicção justamente determina que na
possibilidade de uma pessoa perder um bem que
ela adquiriu por um motivo anterior à aquisição
daquele bem, ela deve receber todo o valor
que ela pagou de volta e esse valor
vai ser corrigido por algum índice determinado no
edital do leilão.
Pode ser que o índice previsto seja o
IGPM, pode ser que o índice previsto seja
de acordo com a inflação ou algum outro
índice que o edital disponibilize.
Então, para um caso prático de um leilão,
onde a pessoa é interessada em arrematar, tome
ciência que existe uma ação de consignação em
pagamento, essa pessoa, ela deve ter em mente
que pode ser uma remota chance que aquela
ação de consignação em pagamento seja julgada procedente
ao final.
E ela sendo julgada procedente, pode ser que
o juiz determine que aquele leilão não poderia
ter ocorrido, que aquele leilão ele deve ser
anulado, mas pode ser que aquele leilão já
tenha uma arrematação.
Então, se o juiz decidir ao final de
uma ação de consignação em pagamento que aquele
leilão deveria ser anulado, então que o arrematante
não poderá ficar com aquele bem, o arrematante
não vai perder o dinheiro que ele investiu
para comprar aquele bem, aquele valor deve ser
restituído ao arrematante.
Esse mesmo raciocínio se aplica a qualquer outra
ação que possa existir anteriormente ao leilão.
Uma ação anulatória do leilão, uma ação anulatória
de uma transferência de propriedade, a consolidação da
propriedade nada mais é do que uma transferência
de propriedade.
Pode ser que o devedor ele entre com
uma ação para anular essa consolidação da propriedade,
pode ser que ele alegue que ele não
foi efetivamente constituído em mora, ou seja, que
ele não foi informado de que ele estava
devendo oficialmente, então não ocorreu aquele prazo de
15 dias para que ele pudesse pagar o
que ele estava devendo, então ele vai tentar
entrar em uma ação anulatória para desconstituir a
consolidação da propriedade em nome do credor.
Então, qualquer ação que exista anteriormente à arrematação
vai entrar aquilo que a gente chamou de
evicção de direito.
Caso a justiça depois determine que aquele leilão
não poderia ter acontecido, que aquela arrematação que
ocorreu naquele leilão é nula, que aquele leilão
deve ser anulado, o arrematante ele vai ter
direito a receber aquilo que ele pagou.
Então vamos mostrar na prática como é que
o edital de um leilão excrediticial fala sobre
evicção de direitos.
Eu tô aqui com um edital aberto que
vai ser realizado pelo Banco Santander e aqui
está a parte do edital que fala sobre
evicção.
Se assim ficou consignado que seria a responsabilidade
do arrematante pelos débitos de condomínio e IPTU,
até mesmo antes da data do leilão, somente
para o imóvel vendido na condição de ocupado
das despesas condominiais e tributos comprovadamente pagos pelo
arrematante, custos e emolumentos cartorários pagos em razão
da outorga e registro da escritura definitiva de
compra de imóvel.
Ou seja, aqui o Santander fala que ele
vai devolver tudo que o arrematante pagou, porque
tudo aquilo que o arrematante pagou está aqui
explícito nesse edital do Santander.
E agora eu queria mostrar um outro edital
de um leilão, que é um edital do
Banco Itaú, de um leilão excrediticial, e esse
edital ele também fala de evicção, mas ele
faz uma ressalva.
Vamos ver como é que ele falou de
evicção.
Sobrevendo decisão judicial transitada em julgado que decretar
a anulação do título aquisitivo do vendedor, e
aqui lembrando que a consolidação da propriedade em
nome do credor fiduciário, do vendedor daquele leilão,
é um título aquisitivo de propriedade, afinal o
credor só é o dono daquele imóvel exatamente
porque ele constituiu a propriedade em seu nome,
então a constituição da propriedade em seu nome
é transferência da propriedade definitivamente para o nome
do credor.
Aí o edital coloca, o vendedor responderá pela
evicção de direito com exceção dos imóveis em
cuja descrição constante do site do leiloeiro ou
material de divulgação haja referência à rescrição judicial
ou outra especificação.
O que esse edital do Itaú está falando
sobre evicção então?
Está falando que se caso leiloeiro ou algum
outro material de divulgação daquele leilão informar que
existia uma ação judicial prévia sobre aquele imóvel
e depois essa ação judicial prévia for julgada
procedente e o leilão for anulado, que o
Itaú não devolverá aquilo que o arrematante pagou.
E aqui eu queria deixar um ponto bem
claro para vocês, essa disposição desse edital especificamente
ou de algum outro edital que traga esses
mesmos termos pode ser contestada na justiça, mas
o objetivo de todo mundo que arremata um
imóvel e leilão é ficar com o imóvel
e não gerar discussão por aquele imóvel, então
se o edital já tivesse a disposição e
se o leiloeiro informar que existe uma ação
judicial prévia sobre aquele imóvel e aí não
basta que o leiloeiro faça uma menção genérica
de pode ser que exista uma ação judicial
prévia, o leiloeiro ele efetivamente deve informar a
ação, inclusive colocar o número da ação judicial
que está em andamento.
Se for o caso de existir essa ação
judicial prévia e do edital colocar essa previsão
parecida com o que o Itaú está falando
aqui nesse edital dele, avalie a possibilidade de
você participar ou não daquele leilão, isso porque
pode ser que essa ação judicial prévia seja
julgada procedente ao final e que aquele leilão
seja anulado, então que a sua arrematação vai
ser anulada também e aí nesse caso você
teria que criar uma briga com o Itaú
para você receber o que você pagou e
esse não é o objetivo de ninguém aqui,
o objetivo é que o edital já seja
uma proteção da evicção de direito, então que
o edital fale que se aquele leilão for
anulado você vai receber tudo previamente, então fique
atento aos casos em que o edital coloque
essa exceção para que a evicção seja realizada,
para que essa exceção seja realizada, o leiloeiro
ou alguma outra fonte de informação daquele leilão
vai ter que efetivamente informar que existe uma
ação judicial prévia e aí caso o leiloeiro
informe que existe uma ação judicial prévia, o
que eu recomendo pra você?
Entre em contato com o leiloeiro pra saber
como está aquela ação, porque pode até ser
que aquela ação judicial já tenha sido julgada
em procedente pelo Poder Judiciário, mas que ainda
consta que aquela informação ali, exatamente porque o
leiloeiro, ele é obrigado a informar, então se
aquela ação já foi julgada em procedente, você
pode arrematar com tranquilidade, porque ela já foi
julgada em procedente, então o risco que você
assumiria, você não vai mais assumir exatamente porque
ela foi julgada em procedente, então tenha sempre
isso em mente quanto a evicção de direitos,
em regra se você arrematar um imóvel e
esse leilão for anulado posteriormente pela justiça, você
terá direito a receber tudo aquilo que você
pagou por aquele imóvel, porque existe a chamada
evicção de direitos e os editais dos leilões
extrajudiciais fazem expressamente menção à evicção dos direitos.
Fique atento aos editais de leilão extrajudicial que
vão colocar essa ressalva, qual é essa ressalva?
A ressalva de que se o leiloeiro informar
que existe uma ação judicial prévia, o arrematante
vai assumir o risco por aquela ação, ou
seja, se aquela ação for julgada procedente e
o leilão for anulado, que ele não poderá
pleitear a restituição daqueles valores que ele pagou,
então fique atento a isso, se existir a
menção a uma ação de consignação em pagamento
ou qualquer outro tipo de ação prévia à
realização do leilão, veja o que fala o
edital, se o edital colocar essa exceção na
evicção de direitos informando que caso o arrematante
tenha ciência de que existe aquela ação em
andamento e pra ele ter ciência, o leiloeiro
deve informar, ele não tem que buscar a
existência dessas ações, essa informação tem que chegar
pronta para o arrematante, pode ser que ele
não consiga pleitear a restituição dos valores que
ele pagou se essa ação for julgada procedente
e o leilão for anulado, então quando você
analisar o edital do leilão e as informações
do leiloeiro sobre aquele determinado imóvel, se não
existir nenhuma menção a uma ação judicial prévia,
você pode arrematar sem medo que você estará
amparado pela evicção de direitos, porque você não
pode assumir o risco pelo que você não
foi informado, então se o leiloeiro não te
informa a ação judicial prévia, você não assume
o risco, você estará automaticamente amparado pela evicção
de direitos, se aquele leilão for anulado, você
vai receber tudo aquilo que você pagou corrigido
pelo índice estabelecido no edital, agora se você
se deparar com um imóvel de sem interesse
e ao analisar as informações do leiloeiro e
do edital, você verificar que existe uma ação
prévia tentando anular aquele leilão e o edital
colocar expressamente que a evicção de direitos não
acontecerá, se você for informado previamente de que
existe uma ação, avalie a possibilidade ou não
de você participar daquele leilão, entre em contato
com o leiloeiro e peça para que ele
te informe qual é o andamento daquela ação,
pode ser que ele informe que aquela ação
até mesmo já não existe mais, mas ele
informou porque ele é obrigado a informar, e
se aquela ação estiver em andamento, avalie a
possibilidade de você ficar fora daquele leilão, afinal
sempre existe um próximo leilão, existem leilões todos
os dias, centenas de leilões todos os dias,
você não participar daquele especificamente, não esclarará prejuízo
algum, tenha sempre em mente que ao participar
de um leilão, tudo que você quer é
ficar com aquele imóvel e não depois ter
aquele valor restituído ou até mesmo ter algum
problema para tentar a restituição daquele valor, então
fique sempre atento aos casos em que haverá
menção de ação judicial prévia para tentar anular
aquele leilão judicial, para tentar anular aquela consolidação
da propriedade realizada pelo credor.